you might go damn dude you must be a
genius you're [__] 17 year old doctor
all right here's my dick check it out
you know like because you're sucking
[Music]
all right this is a little bit of a sad
story so Nick don't be laughing too
early all right now I'm gonna laugh the
whole time I think all right I'm just
saying it's all laugh let's laugh let's
go all right get your laptop right now
no no no do it I'm gonna laugh during
the story during the story all right man
oh it's gonna be sad all right there's a
Florida dude
that's funny that's funny that's funny
Florida dude that's funny he eats Gators
accused of posing as a posing sonarian
Ventura operates on a pregnant dog oh no
gives this dog a C-section
and then obviously uh kills the dog
doesn't do a good job doesn't use actual
and medically you know correct sutures
in order to sew this dog back up use
like thread and string and [__] well
that's good later on this dog God has uh
multiple complications from the surgery
and eventually he dies six-year-old
chihuahua named sugar
cute laughter that's tough hi everybody
hi Dr Nick
bro how do you pose as a [__] vet ask
Dr Nick
I
just who do you think you know someone
man yeah yeah yeah Joe's the ultimate
wildcard
yes how do you pretend do you go to uh
like a hospital and pretend to be the
vet there or did he pretend himself like
hi I'm a vet like at home oh
um we're like oh yeah it all it says is
uh he was never a vet this six-year-old
Chihuahua was having difficulty
delivering her puppies in May when her
owners contacted this guy named Sanchez
who had previously introduced himself as
a vet to the couple oh no so Sanchez
visited the home on May 18th to evaluate
sugar it's funny that's getting caught
up in your life what if it's like an ego
thing it's like [__] I shouldn't have
said that I was a vet he's delusional I
know a vet call Sanchez and he's like oh
yeah I'll be right over
evaluates sugar and performs a C-section
and spay procedure on the six pound dog
in his mobile office space his mobile
office during the surgery he removes a
stillborn puppies Tacoma oh God yeah you
remove the stillborn puppy and charged
Sugar's owners 600 for the procedure
that's a good deal
grifter then but did he use anesthesia
or did he just go straight in you think
this guy has anesthesia he didn't even
have
to have [__] cookie box and he's like
I mean it's a miscellaneous drawer he's
got like salad pass okay
yarn
we died anyway
well there was a bunch of puppies right
one of them either way sugar was already
having a hard time delivering her
puppies so that's why they contacted
Sanchez Sanchez is already bro would you
ever just go to a random guy he said
he's a vet that's tough dude but I guess
this is the primary you guys been
friends for so long you're like oh I
know a vet yeah and then you're like hey
vet friend emergency because I think a
lot of dog owners will be in this
situation and be like dude the vet's so
expensive we'll do anything to not go to
the next it's funny that [__] like this
happens like when people fake a job for
like clout they pick something that's so
hard to [__] fake yeah you can't fake
them like you need massive skill yeah
cause there's so many fake doctors in
the world like there's so many guys that
lie about being a doc remember the guy
that was the OB GYN for like [__] six
months and he was like 19 years old it's
like what the [__] how did you serve
that many people but I think you know
what it is for that one I think it was
smart because he walked into a hospital
and the setting [__] with you because
if you're in Kaiser Permanente yeah you
might go damn dude you must be a genius
your [__] 17 year old doctor all
right here's my dick check it out you
know like because you're sucking because
you're in a you're in a legit hospital
so like I think like that would like but
if if you're if if he pulls up in a
trailer yeah and on the trailer it's
just spray painted Hospital yeah or
ambulance I'd be like I remember it's
pretty legit in Patch Adams all he did
was go to some like butchers or meat
convention grab a white coat and walk
back into the hospital cover the patch
and then was able to be a doctor for
like that [__] was smart though
he was smart smart ass doctor smart ass
me but maybe Sanchez was like a guy that
just really wanted to [__] up animals oh
interesting like he was just doing that
to [__] up animals not because he wanted
to be that's true he's just calling
people like maybe he's done this to a
bunch of different dogs and [__] them
all up yeah like I want to know more
more about the Sanchez guy like I want
to know like what what is he actually
like is he Mexican is he Filipino he's a
white guy yeah he's not he's probably
not Sanchez you pull up to a Sanchez's
house and he's a white guy probably some
Asian dude like hello yeah my name is
Sanchez Sanchez I do for you you have
problems Sanchez it's the shrug for me
he's not sure about it too the super
nonchalant
whatever don't worry yeah yeah according
to detective Sanchez was not a licensed
veterinarian but he was a licensed pet
groomer
whoa what if it's one of them so the dog
looks great
what if it's one of those things where
he's like kind of ashamed of his role
as a pet groomer but he works with pets
so he just elevated it like I'm a vet oh
wow you're there oh yeah it could be
that too yeah there's people that do
that because then he's like yeah I'm you
know so he's always with his dogs and
cats and [__] and they're like oh he's a
bad this is like a Dwight shoot where
it's like yeah I'm a assistant regional
manager assistant to the regional man
you know what I mean it's like you
glorify your position but then still
like [__] that moment where you're
like I gotta do a C-section on an animal
now when usually I just groom right I
would just say I'm not available
what if it was one of those things where
they're like hey can you come over I
need help with the puppy right and then
they're like okay and he comes over and
then then they go it's pregnant what do
we do Doc and you're like oh [__] I'm
here now and the guys have gotten like
you better [__] operate on my [__]
dog right now that changes things yeah
yeah and he's like okay his back was
against me
he's still calm and then maybe he didn't
have the materials he goes oh no I
didn't bring my materials they're like
we have yarn no he makes an incision
he's like whoopsies
[Music]
you wanted this
you asked for it this seems like a
scammer you think so yeah he sounds
professional scam dude but man once
they're like we got 600 bucks he's like
yeah I could do it yeah
I got their money's worth that's pretty
cheap isn't it they didn't they scam
themselves they're the ones that get
older yeah and then they're like look at
the dog how much and he's like I don't
know 600. okay how much you got deal I
would never [__] take my pet to a
[__] mobile no well yeah I mean you
have exotic wonderful cats like this guy
just had a Chihuahua stupid little
Chihuahua my first dog was a Chihuahua I
feel like some people love the deals
like some people no matter what if they
could get a discount
not for sure especially with pets though
the Chihuahua her name was Didi it was
actually it stood for a Dodge dog just
like the [__] hat that you're wearing
did you train them for a Dodger tickets
or something yeah yeah that's right that
was the story you told us well you
traded him in for Dodgers no no I traded
Dodgers tickets
I was like why are we so calm I remember
when I was playing a dog yes whatever I
remember yeah
parking lot at Home Depot and this
dude's like selling [__] baby
Chihuahuas and stuff he's like hey
Dodgers tickets yeah and I was like he
had a Dodger sticker on the back of his
car I was like hey you like Doug he's
like yeah what oh is that when you were
working like selling the tickets oh yes
I always had tickets he's like I'm a pet
groomer
when you saw the tickets you just sell
them for just more money or how they
were like discount tickets in like a
packet like coupon tickets yeah we
explained this before feel free to
reference like 600 videos ago yeah yeah
I'll look at it just tell me what video
to watch and then I'll watch it so we're
gonna talk about it right now yeah it's
the uh just watch it really quick right
now 19 year old kid fakes being OBG
YN
but yeah
and that's then you traded that for
Laker sticks
where did we get how did we get there
hey Nick or your uh pugs able to do
natural birth yeah dude my my
mother-in-law delivered them she was
watching YouTube videos bro she she did
she delivered them bro what what's her
name Mrs Sanchez no dude no C-section
all natural because I thought like pugs
you have to do those C-sections honestly
when the puppies were being born I was
like one of them's gonna die I was like
one of them has to die like because
that's what they everyone told me that
they were like oh and they're so small
yeah you got to keep them warm because
you gotta like you gotta do a lot you
really don't have to do anything because
it's just natural right you just watch
them they'll just do it it's natural
well some doggies I I heard you you
can't like a bulldog you had to like
take them out and then like rip the sack
so they could breathe you know like that
was oh they came out in little sacks
that's what she said what do you mean
little sacks hey little eggs
I don't know like it was that's what she
was explaining she didn't like no I
never you ever seen like a [__]
giraffe get born and it's still got like
the film is that the placenta I've never
really actually what's plus
he said placenta
I'm sorry I said that it makes me sound
like I don't know what it is did it come
out with a little thing a shelf
sometimes there's a pretty good uh
there's a pretty good movie called
Jurassic Park that probably shows all
the details I saw I mean I saw Jurassic
Park I saw a little egg so you'll see
like Safari videos and stuff like that
and animal will fall out the [__] ass
I saw Jim Carrey come out like that yeah
kind of like that I like that yeah but
it's got like this film and then they
gotta like rip through the film and
stuff but sometimes the baby can't rip
through it it's just like blind or
whatever and then the mother will
literally eat that like or rip it with
their own teeth and stuff so my
mother-in-law did all that stuff you
weren't there it was at like 3 A.M and
she she was she was giving birth from
like 3 A.M to like 7 A.M and my
mother-in-law was doing it all night
with her wow she's a [__] beast I
would have been scared as hell dude I
wouldn't know what to do deliver dogs
nuts it's crazy that's kind of easier
than a human that's very true humans you
gotta go longer and you only get one
yeah at least dogs you can get a bunch
of them and you sometimes you get more
than one human my mother-in-law's a
doggy Doula dude she [__] delivered
those babies I would probably turn to
YouTube as well that dude she was and we
didn't even know that she was she's been
studying she's been upskilling oh really
yeah her doodle abilities was she
watching Sanchez's YouTube channel yeah
it was actually very helpful for her she
said
it's all in Spanish that's what I do
that'd be sick if you looked up her her
YouTube uh history and it says like how
to kill your son-in-law
that'll be cool yeah
whoa and he was like oh normally Huss
not you it's the other one I'm a little
scared now
oh [__] wrong video
[Music]